[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh did
I interrupt you brooding just now times
have changed you need to change with
them we have to be tough and
battle-ready
Oh
hurry the door is slowly closing
oh the pain its gain so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
we're going I don't get it we'll help me
rescue my friends it's ruled by an alien
queen only the toughest you're gonna get
out of there alive
I'm the queen whatever I would not be
I'm getting super evil vibes here I
could change my form to something else
if this makes you uncomfortable
hey guys he'll go back the horse was
much more palatable
[Music]
did you draw double dots on your face
who are you I'm your worst nightmare
Oh me when I'm late to school and I
forgot my homework and my pants are made
of pudding no I don't a lifetime has
passed since the horrific events of Taco
Tuesday our lives descended into chaos
this new life has toughened and hardened
two copies please
one black one with just a touch of cream
in 25 sugars well stuff in most of us I
wake up in the morning morning morning
sewer babies Amit you've gotta stop
pretending everything is awesome
it isn't yeah I get it and that's why
I've cultivated a totally hard-edged
side that's super tough and
Oh something new what is it up to but
that beat is pretty fresh
[Music]
[Music]
it's like it knows our every move weird
right special this guy was a fierce
warrior
okay well technically I did the warrior
sir so you fought a masterbuilt and hit
but and then the hapless male was the
leader here well
[Music]
hang on to your fronds planning we're
going to save Lucy and all of the other
people who were captured
[Music]
behold the sISTAR sister do not give her
the satisfaction of wooing this
[Music]
[Music]